Have you heard of the Millennium Falcon?...
you know, the ship that made the Kessel Run
in less than twelve parsecs!
Nevermind the mistaken parlance -- how fast
IS that old bucket of bolts?
Happy May the 4th padawans!
Today, on Star Wars appreciation day, we thought
we’d pull some of the magic out of the fabric
of space time.
See, every nerf herder in the ‘verse knows
that Han Solo’s ship is fast, but even in
a galaxy far, far away the laws of physics
should still apply.
So based on our physics, could the Falcon
actually do this?
Firstly, let me just say clearly… nah.
Laugh.
Nah.
The special theory of relativity has shown
the faster we travel: ONE the slower time
moves for us, and TWO the more mass we gain.
So a ship travelling at, quote, “Point five
past light speed” (whatever that means)
would have ridiculous mass and require humongous
energies to accelerate and decelerate.
Plus, even at 1.5 times the speed of light
-- planets and stars are really far apart.
Even if point-five is 1.5 times the speed
of light it would still take five and a half
minutes to go from the sun to earth -- and
even at its closest -- 2 hours and 45 minutes
to get to Pluto!
And let’s say you could actually travel
the speed of light, even for a minute.
It wouldn’t look all blue and streaky either.
A study from 2013 did the math, and in reality
you’d see this:
Basically, the Doppler effect comes into play.
Doppler shift means as you go faster, waves
of energy appear to shorten.
So the screech of a Tie Fighter or ambulance
is higher as it approaches you than after
it passes you.
This blue shift would turn visible light into
the x-ray range, and the Cosmic Microwave
Background Radiation -- super dim leftover
light from the Big Bang that permeates the
universe would be accelerated to the point
of being visible.
Amazing!
But... impossible, based on our physics.
You’ve probably heard of wormholes -- used
in Contact, Interstellar, and my fav fav fav
Stargate SG-1.
Wormholes ARE an option according to physicists,
mathematically they could exist, but the energy
required to create and maintain them is astronomical.
Let’s just say, this is Beyond our understanding
right now.
So, to find out what might not be, I reached
out to physicists Dr. Casey Handmer and he
said, "if you ask an expert ‘Is FTL travel
impossible?’ the answer is only ‘probably.’
Under the rules we understand, it is cannot
yet be ruled out.
Because time travel is somewhat similar, we
can't yet rule it out either.
There are several strong hints that physics
may permit FTL travel, ranging from the quantum
physics of the very small and very cold, to
astrophysics and cosmology, which studies
the universe at the largest scales.
These hints warrant further investigation."
There is, of course, another option, the hyperdrive
somehow jumps the ship OUT of our dimension
of spacetime -- meaning we don’t have to
contend with boring old laws of physics.
String theory says that there are higher dimensions
that behave differently, but we’re just
beginning to understand that, and as Casey
told me, any self-respecting physicist would
respond to faster-than-light travel with a
big shrug.
All this just shows, that even a long-long
time ago in a galaxy far far away a smuggler
could have taken our smartest minds to school
on higher physics.
For more about the science in the movies you
love, you should absolutely check out Seeker’s
new podcast, Bad Science -- it’s fantastic
-- there my buddy Ethan will talk about the
science in movies every week, but with EXPERTS
to bring it into reality.
Some things are possible, some things… eehhh…
Tune in wherever you get your podcasts, there’s
link in the description.
Science doesn’t ruin everything, take parallel
universes for instance.
Watch this video about where one might have
bumped into ours!
One last thing, some nerds did the calculations,
and the Falcon might top out at over 1041
light-years/hour.
Sar Trek’s Warp 8?
Only zero point six light-years/hour.
Sorry Jean Luc.